Favi welcome back to the studio
congratulations back to back victories
and quite an important one with the
black pieces against the co-leader Hans
Neiman how does that feel
I mean right now I feel exhausted I was
hoping I would give you an interesting
interview
um I was hoping to keep the trend up but
I don't have enough energy for that how
come did you feel disrespected in any
way coming into today's round on every
level
no I I don't really I mean it was a very
difficult game but it shouldn't have
been because
I got such a dominant position at some
point let's talk about the game out of
the opening it did feel like okay I
don't know what he was preparing because
I played this line in the last game
against Hare Krishna in the Olympia so
he seemed surprised I mean
it's not like I had some new idea in
mind I was just repeating exactly my
game uh
Hari played E3 five and we made a quick
draw yeah and it looked like Hans was
somewhat surprised that I played this so
I I don't know maybe he missed
did you get to chat with him after the
game at all I don't think he wants to
chat him with me anymore okay okay I
think we're no longer on chatting terms
okay Queen C3 uh Rook D1 E5 and you were
mentioning that you had this prepared
and you were playing quite quickly he
wasn't or he's surprised by that yeah he
was thinking I I was actually worried I
thought he might come to this game with
some some prep I didn't remember the
line too well and but I thought
um anyway I should play it and say
principled and then yeah I played a rare
move Bishop F5 I was hoping that even if
he knows the line of it that this would
be a rare a surprise for him because
Bishop G4 I think is the main move yeah
if I remember before C6 Bishop there was
this important game Sam against Hikaru
it was uh last year and I think the
rapid St Louis rapid
and then they made a draw it was a very
correct game but black suffers a bit
there and here it's more of a fighting
position and yeah he played a very
surprising move A4
I thought that Bishop B5 is the correct
move I couldn't remember exactly I think
that was correct I think Bishop E5 was
the correct move of course white does
have some freedom of choice I mean
it's clearly white is marginally better
here but uh yeah here I was going to
play A6 take 92 and I was not sure if I
can play E4 here one option so you were
out of this out of your book at this
point I mean I I have some like fake
general knowledge not very I don't
didn't recollect it so well I thought E4
was played in this game bronze funny
because and it looked very logical but
of course it's a bit positionally risky
maybe I'm just mixing things up
completely I think it is
yeah that's a better version yeah so
this was the game but I was wondering if
I could instead of instead of this place
C6 I was trying to figure out this
position here instead of uh Bishop B5
C6 yes I thought D6 is forced
and here the problem is Queen D6 he has
not Knight E4 but Knight C4
and I can't go to G6 because well root
t7 Rook day seven so
so I was going to play while I was
thinking about it I wasn't sure I was
gonna play C6 but c66 I was going to
play Queen G6
um yeah I thought F3 is very logical
Rook cd8
and this position I was trying to figure
out it didn't look clear to me see the
computer really hates it
maybe Queen G6 is not accurate maybe
Rook cd8 first
but I thought that I should
yeah I wasn't sure I would do this but I
yeah Rook CA first ah this is 94 Queen
G6 F3 I I was looking for another move
order but maybe I get it here and then
Bishop F5 I thought I should be okay
Knight G3 yeah and yeah then I forced
him to take the bishop with H5 at some
point he'll take and then I just
blockade his D pawn and I thought
yeah take take he plays
yeah and I also have some uh H3 ideas at
some moment so I thought I thought I
should be completely fine here
um but then he surprised me A4 I got
very ambitious suddenly
okay he played C6 immediately D6
and this is the move that surprised us
H3 yeah I didn't I I didn't expect gf3
I mean which was probably the best path
forward that this yeah yeah actually
came as a surprise I was thinking some
other move like Queen before was
interesting I think that was the best
movie in the position some sort of mess
after e494 maybe he just saw a C5 here
and thought uh thought he shouldn't do
this
um but yeah but it doesn't work Bishop
G4 and D7 singing yep but I don't like
if I take only two B6 his Pawn is not so
dangerous
um
but yeah he was also getting low on time
so I understand why he started to play
rather quickly but but probably not very
accurately and he played H3 and at this
point he felt like you're slowly taking
over but he was still fighting yeah
something maybe rookie 6 wasn't accurate
or something because I thought I had a
better Advantage than what I got
Square to put the Rook
yeah I think
at this point it felt like you were
completely done maybe kimchi summer was
bad I was not hesitating I thought maybe
four
I mean okay it can't be a bad move but
actually 494 I thought this
yeah Queen F4 and now maybe I take take
and Rook D6 is this uh
is this just winning King 2 Knight C5 I
trade
Bishop C2 I wasn't 100 sure take take an
F5 but it's of course a bit difficult
which we wanted five he puts a king on
E3 my pawns are on light squares it
might be difficult to win this yeah uh I
wasn't sure and I thought okay I'll just
make a safe move King G7 and then he
played a very good good movie E4 and
it's suddenly difficult for black to
um to handle this position I mean of
course I should be winning but the path
wasn't clear I mean Knight B5 I I was
thinking take Rook D5 I mean my pawns
are really I'm really tied up yeah A6
but I just wasn't sure after King G2 how
I continue this yeah and it's not clear
at all yeah computer says Queen F4 but I
mean yeah I was a bit worried that maybe
this is a very trash in general so I
wasn't sure yep yep
and you played Queen to E7 trying to
escape the queen trade Queen G5
and then you guys got it yeah
maybe this was inaccurate but I was low
on time I just I thought okay I'll
create a passport and try to get the F4
Square for either my king or Knight yep
and it was this moment yeah I should
have played of course Knight B6 I was
trying that's what I tried to get but it
was like the time control so I thought
okay yeah this this is of course a
better try than
and if he goes back to
e27 yeah
this is what I wanted what I was going
to do after the time control but then he
played F4
if he played Bishop A6 back I would have
gone to B6
and then yeah this is took
and then this was the critical model
Rook to E5 yeah C4 uh he's okay here
I thought I was winning only with Rook
A6
oh yeah we're okay six
um I thought 93 is winning King F2
yeah take take rookie four
Maybe
if this is a draw
maybe
I don't
if I was winning
ah but he just has Rook h8 yeah maybe
okay yeah yeah okay I mean it's well
draw is like you know two poems kind of
draw yeah in time trouble but F3 yeah
but it is a drawn ending with the two
pawns yeah
um I I just didn't see this work h8 I
thought I'll get my Rook to the side and
then his B Pawn is less important than
my three pawns if I could keep all three
then I would win
um and he didn't probably assess it
correctly either uh because he did play
this move King to G2 after a long thing
yeah 15 minutes I think I think he had a
lot of time I had like seven minutes I
don't remember what he had maybe 25 or
so 22 and he dropped down to his last
seven yeah he went he got equal with me
on time and then I thought maybe King G5
wasn't the most accurate I was
hesitating like Rook B8 is also very
very strong I thought
but then I was like okay King G5 is more
natural let's and I saw this whole Rook
a rook h8
and when I played King G5 I thought yeah
Rook H5 Rook B5
and I was really counting on F6 here
Rook F4 yeah Knight D3 yep Rook H4 Rook
H5 yeah okay 12 Knight of four yeah King
G4 take a look at this line and yeah and
the King comes back after C5 but then I
was like yeah this is a drop but I was
thinking maybe King E6 F4 F5 but then he
has King G6 which is a draw
because if C5 he just gets back yeah and
then King G6 take F5 and we get the C
Pawn which uh yeah can go somewhere
which
I don't know like some of these
positions are losing somewhere a draw I
assume the C Pawn is actually winning
for black usually like the central pawns
or or better winning chances but here of
course the pawn isn't very far advanced
but like a and b are it's difficult to
win yeah on you get some shots like D or
E if it's Advanced then it's just
apparently it's winning yeah yeah the
central pawns are really hard to defend
but then I couldn't like decide on this
I had just a little time I mean I saw
that I could go for this but
there was I thought okay The Rook ending
feels like it should be winning but I
was really unsure and of course
surprised me a bit actually yeah
it was a draw but only with yes F4
surprised me I mean Rook G1 I was gonna
play Rook C5 I think root G2 was the
best move I can't imagine why would yeah
I understand okay so rookie one let's I
mean let's try to stay with a human
Rook C5 I need to go because I can't
allow Works you're planning on playing
this yeah King G4 work C2 and F4
I thought this was winning take King
takes H3 but I wasn't sure it's very
you know his work has to go behind the
pawn yeah but how he does that I don't
know
and it might turn into some sort of race
so and he played he made this final
mistake F4 but I wasn't sure this was
winning I mean it's like it's easy of
course when when you see the engine but
it's very close very close to being a
draw I assumed he he thought it was a
draw yeah but yeah it was Fabiano uh
plus two after four rounds how are you
seeing uh the start to this tournament
so far how are you feeling about it well
it's good but I I am exhausted now I
mean this was a tough game and uh
the first three games I wasn't like
under time pressure but once you get a
long game where you deal with time
trouble then
um then you really feel it the tiredness
so and I think tomorrow I play Wesley
which is a very important game big round
tomorrow we'll let you go get your rest
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank
you
congratulations